all right Kathy it is Bravo con weekend
you're gonna ham it up with all the
hunky dory people out there yeah are you
pouring Casa del Sol for these people I
I've got some in the trunk always
available
uh we are about to watch your parts of
the Beverly Hills reunion the trailer
you came in hot what you did to my
sister and you drove Lisa Vanderpump off
the show I mean the list can go on and
on did you come with a game plan did you
have a mission that day or did you
surprise yourself with how intense you
were you know when you're passionate
about something and there's eight women
on the show so
there's times you try to say something
or get something
and it's cut
I can't use everything so I wanted to
make sure
that I got my points across so hopefully
that they will use it did you get what
you needed out of that day
um
well I think the most important thing is
that uh it's I don't know because it's
frustrating
I feel like
that
what was said I apologized but I didn't
know what I was apologizing for because
a couple episodes later
we see what she said about me and
it's just interesting because she would
say I get it I get it I got it uh you're
preaching to the choir
and agreed with me on so many things and
then to start all this
um is just really frustrating yeah you
didn't think she was gonna take any
private conversation well no to change
the conversation around
so where do you two stand after reunion
I have no idea
what about you and Kyle where do you
guys go from here we've been texting and
uh she's been in New York here for a few
days before I got here so
I got one more question for you
Lisa Renaissance you're jealous of the
Kardashians then Kris Jenner's been
showing you a lot of love on Instagram
what does that mean to you Chris is like
my sister you know we've known each
other for 38 years
so no jealousy no no I love her
enjoy the weekend
foreign